[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight the president held his
first news conference in over a year
this afternoon he took questions for an
hour and 21 minutes and 44 seconds cuz
we were counting it was mostly about
Brett Kavanaugh a Supreme Court
nomination in case you missed it here's
part of what he said they've destroyed a
man's reputation and they want to
destroy it even more and I think people
are going to see that in the midterms
what they've done to this family what
they've done to these children these
beautiful children of his and what
they've done to his wife and they know
it's a big fat con job and they go into
a room and I guarantee you they laugh
like hell 36 years there's no charge
all of a sudden the hearings are over
and the rumors start coming out and then
you have this other con artist avenatti
come out with another beauty today
look these are very dishonest people
these are con artists and the press
knows it but the press doesn't write it
I could pick another Supreme Court judge
justice I could pick another one another
one another one this could go on forever
somebody could come and say 30 years ago
25 years ago ten years ago five years
ago he did a horrible thing to me this
is just a game that they're playing it's
a con game it's at the highest level
we're talking about the United States
Supreme Court we're an exhibit to cover
this story all night tonight and
obviously throughout the weekend into
next there are many strains of it now
one thing we learned today for certain
though Democrats badly want control the
Supreme Court it's all that matters to
them at the moment and they will do
whatever it takes and they are the
latest exhibit comes from the lawyer for
pornographic actress stormy Daniels whom
as you have heard by now has a new
client tonight her name is Julie sweat
Nick and she alleges that about 35 years
ago Supreme Court nominee Brett
Kavanaugh was part of a group of
teenaged boys in the Washington DC area
who committed a series of gang rapes
Cavanaugh himself seemed bewildered
today when he was asked about this claim
he
described it as like being part of an
episode of The Twilight Zone many
observers felt the same way about it in
the coming days we'll have times who
carefully assess all of these claims of
the many counterclaims in this story and
of course we'll bring all of that to you
but tonight we're going to start with
some questions and several come to mind
here's the most obvious one what exactly
is the allegation here in this new claim
Democratic Senator Richard Blumenthal of
Connecticut did not hesitate to give his
assessment of what it is watch what we
have now for the first time is a sworn
affidavit
that specifically identifies breadkappa
as seemingly raping a woman who has been
drugged
seemingly raped says senator Blumenthal
what does that mean it's important to
ask because everything turns on that
question he's sweating it claiming that
Brett Kavanaugh raped her is she saying
someone else raped her
if so who exactly is this person and
where is this person today did Brett
Kavanaugh commit rape none of that is
clear from sweat nick's account which is
far more suggesting than it does stating
read it yourself and see now sweating
does claim that she herself was raped by
a number of boys was Brett Kavanaugh
among them we don't know which itself
raises more basic question why doesn't
sweat anacs sworn and written statements
spell out clearly what she claims Brett
Kavanaugh did what is clear is that
according to Julie sweat neck horrible
things happened at a series of parties
in suburban Maryland in the 1980s we're
not talking drunken high school
naughtiness these are war crimes level
atrocities the kinds of crimes the UN
investigates in third world countries
groups of young women drugged and
gang-raped it's horrifying
so why isn't anyone taken all of this to
law enforcement sweat Knicks lawyers
sent her claims to the media as he
always does did he contact a Maryland
police first they're the ones with
jurisdiction here are they investigating
this is this the first time they have
seen these allegations and if it is the
first time how can that be
sweat Nick describes attending at least
10 parties at which public drugging and
raping took place boys were lined up in
a queue to commit rape she claims in
full view of everyone did any of the
many people at these rape scenes mention
these crimes to anyone to police to
their parents or their friends then or
in the years since Washington is a very
small place you may have noticed that
even following the coverage of the
Cavanaugh story among the permanent
population here everyone knows everyone
or knows someone who does so where all
the witnesses to this where are the
people who would have spoken to
witnesses about it over the past 35
years did sweating herself tell anyone
over that time Cavanaugh's attorney Beth
Wilkinson raised these questions today
I've had people call me and email me
saying they know him they were at the
parties they never met her they've never
seen her and they've never heard of any
of these allegations I've got to believe
that if this was happening over two
years with all these women and all these
men someone else would have heard about
it and would have reported it by now
fair questions what's the answer and by
the way what was Julie sweat Nick doing
at these parties sweat Nick apparently
graduated from high school in 1980 that
means she would have been in college at
the time they took place and yet she
went to parties with high school kids at
these parties she saw horrific gang
rapes but she kept attending the parties
many of them until she herself was
gang-raped and yet she never reported
any of that to police would be
interesting to know why maybe the most
baffling of all though how did the FBI
miss the fact that Brett Kavanaugh was
part of a prolific teenage rape ring
Cavanaugh has been personally
investigated by the FBI six separate
times as part of federal background
checks as staff secretary in the Bush
White House Cavanaugh had the highest
possible security clearance one that
allowed him access to this country's
nuclear codes
FBI agents would have spoken to a huge
variety of people who knew or knew of
Kavanaugh during his high school years
and not one of them mentioned he was a
serial rapist who committed his rapes in
crowded rooms full of classmates how did
that happen and if it did happen we know
that FBI investigators are criminally
incompetent so incompetent they missed a
glaring fact like that so why would he
want them to reinvestigate Brett
Kavanaugh a seventh time normal people
might wonder about all of this not the
media how dare you ask they scold
questions are forbidden here when you
hear Lindsey Graham a sitting senator
say things like I find it curious these
charges were never brought forward until
2018
come on and it's more than that he said
I hope people will be highly suspicious
of the allegation because why would she
go to pretend parties why would any
reasonable person I'm quoting continue
to hang around people like this if you
talk to people in the world
of the people that that advocate for
victims and survivors of sexual violence
sexual assault they call this victim
blaming they call this victim blaming of
course that depends upon who you think
the victim is dumb people on television
have already made up their minds about
that obviously and they'd like you to
shut up but there's no reason you should
you're an American citizen this is your
country it is your Supreme Court it is
your justice system this process is not
belong to cable news anchors or creepy
porn lawyers or even two US senators who
have decided to give up on due process
and instead would like to rule by
accusation and screaming nope it belongs
to you too and you have a right to ask
whatever questions you want and to
expect adult answers and you should